today we're talking about gke image
streaming student success services and
5g network slicing i'm ryan and welcome
to this week in cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news
we're excited to announce the general
availability of a new feature in google
kubernetes engine image streaming this
revolutionary gke feature has the
potential to drastically improve your
application scale up time allowing you
to respond to increased user demand more
rapidly and save money by provisioning
less spare capacity
we achieve this by reducing the image
pull time for your container from
several minutes in the case of large
images to a couple of seconds
irrespective of container size and
allowing your application to start
booting immediately while gke streams
the container data in parallel
a recent survey found that 87 of
companies reported that they are now
experiencing skills gaps now or in the
coming year
and the impact of the pandemic has only
added to the urgency for schools and
education technology companies to find
new ways to support even more learners
to meet these challenges and scale
specialized learning across more
students globally we are expanding our
portfolio of student success services
with a new google cloud artificial
intelligence powered learning platform
which features the interactive tutor
this platform will provide new ways for
educators to share curriculum and will
bring more on-demand learning
opportunities to students
building on the recent releases of the
android 12 operating system and google
distributed cloud google is paving the
way for communication service providers
as well as enterprises to deliver
enterprise applications and services
over 5g network slices for enhanced
application security reliability and
performance
5g network slicing enables virtual
mobile networks to be created
dynamically with varying properties
utilizing shared underlying physical
resources
5g slicing is one of the key areas of
innovations that will let csps earn a
return on their investments in 5g by
offering a secure and dynamic network
platform to enterprises
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud